meanwhile I see cold I was so bored in
the Hilton Kansas City where there's
nothing around you near the airport I
cut my own hair I YouTube had a cut Mon
hair you've been doing that for but I
was bored and I really gave it the old I
gave it the old trim eat rambling well
alright
and I know there are some deficits and
some problems should have [ __ ] [ __ ]
cuts is on here dude I had a
photographer in Milwaukee shot to
Milwaukee and he took pictures on well
send me a picture man thinks everything
on it that's how I look right now guys
what do you mean I don't know this guy
here the Tyler Kenny is yeah brother
Taylor you in
Wow cool man text text my grandma I'm
cutting my hair you know why I'd look
terrible I just I don't know to like I
just don't want to look like this in it
yeah but then also is perfect timing
because Showtime was like oh we're
shooting this funny intro for the
special and they're like oh so you have
to have the same haircut how's it going
I'm growing my hair out like Bradley
Cooper do it well that doesn't work here
and also excuse me sir you and I Bradley
Cooper what are you talking he's like
he's like you hurt my feelings one time
a long time ago we were in [ __ ]
Austin and on a boat and an Aubree was
there and he was wakeboarding
and he's all muscular and out there
there were like a lot of girls around
like every time I felt self-conscious
because I was white and sanity result
Fanny has tattoos you guys have bad but
you at least you're big and handsome and
tattoo and I'm old and skinny and yeah
and I thought to myself when I go my god
I'm looking at Audrey and he had a
shaved head how do I go just like hat to
myself almost I go I gonna shave my head
again and Brennan goes he goes you don't
shave your head you're not gonna look
like Aubrey you're not gonna look like
Aubrey sir you're not gonna look at all
I can you're gonna look like a skinny
guy with a shaved head because you're
gone bald and you're old like he's super
loud and I was like I was like huh
oh and then those cops have stopped us
on the motorboat yeah they kind of
recognize me there's a little better
about myself well there's no recognition
validation oh my god he's so yeah is
Ellen Singh in horseback yeah yeah oh
dude yeah you are my fire the one okay
take the fish I believe when I say I
want it that way but we are two how does
it go to worlds apart can't reach to
your heart the song when you sure you
have you sang this song before I was
younger yeah ah for sure do the country
version yes Wow on it that way but do a
blind but a mistake sorry dude I get
[ __ ] carried away there the octopus
will they caught television occupy just
sang it dude
mmm well with the batch because what's
crazy is though I watch this documentary
on the Backstreet Boys cuz I'm way too
into him there it's crazy out town today
actually are and I'm the only one who is
like I think this from thing is gonna
happen they all said no chance some of
them said no some of them were like and
then when I was unequivocally its it is
actually statistically impossible yeah I
thought well wait a second I'm I mean
I'm I'm from Florida where anything's
possible
and we actually and here that here's the
scary thing the Florida of today is the
America of tomorrow so if you want to
know what challenges will face or
calamities will befall us as a nation in
the years to come don't look I hope the
canary in the coalmine why is it because
of the immigrant the sort of experience
at the melting pot that it is or Miami
doesn't feel like a like part of a
mirror
I was just down there it feels like no
it's not they say the great thing about
Miami is it's so close to the United
States I love it I personally love that
Latin [ __ ] I [ __ ] no no but it's not
wanna lives they're just that Alyssa
really go lip thing I love it I can't
live anyplace else I can't I can't live
out here well they do at least there's
some heartbreak those buildings my
friends a developer down there those
buildings like they sell cocaine money
laundry now now it's money lon well you
got you've got the Porsche building
where you have an elevator in your car
comes up to your apartment yeah and [ __ ]
there's all kinds of that's for Russians
we have a place a neighborhood called
Sunny Isles which is known as little
Moscow and in Sunny Isles we have these
luxurious condos including the Trump
building huh and what happens here is
the Russians that we have on what the
Republicans would go what you [ __ ]
conservatives would call anchor babies
where they bring pregnant Russian women
over who pay tens of thousands of
dollars they buy real estate they buy
condos in the Trump building and buy
condos in Sunny Isles little Moscow in
right just north of Miami Beach and they
come and have their babies here who are
of course now America American babies
those American men hate your bleep aw
American you'll never hear anything
about this from the president he never
complains about the like Russians he
just looks at them as these babies his
future Brides I guess but but the what
the [ __ ] were we taught he was the he
was one of the original Hollywood tough
guys look at him yeah yeah yeah and like
what are the early like actor moguls you
know add like his own production company
yeah own like multi-picture deal David
look at that dividend Culver City
there's the the Kurt Douglas theater
there right yeah
built it with his bare goddamn hand and
sucking looks like just riches [ __ ]
there is now yeah I said my grandma okay
father look how long you know what
father time is like we're gonna he and
he's had his face pulled made a great
run the rule last did a great run my
best I woke up hall-of-fame the other
day and I couldn't move I must
apologizing in my shoulder 40 and hole
someone said well what'd you do I was
like I woke up just what it can all stop
like I didn't I didn't lift a half
gallon of milk or anything here I
just woke up I'm like oh you must have
slept funny I was like no when I see why
those baseball players do all that [ __ ]
I would think about you might be the
only athlete I've ever met
pro athlete who just doesn't have any
injuries it's kind of crazy like it
lengthen yet you don't have any issues
for sure there's keys no because I left
knee gets a little when I was in San
Francisco with Tariq one guy from the
Detroit Lions and another guy from who's
about to go play pro they were just
enormous men and what these were they
were 22 23 and that yeah coming off and
I said weddings well I've had both my
shoulders we've done he's I got two ACLs
I got I was like I mean they're there
they're literally Humpty Dumpty but
they're huge
are they huge I'm not that big these
guys are huge you're pretty big like
Great Danes have issues I'm not that
compared to those guys you know I'm not
great you don't play football for or 20
20 years with seniors at least yeah okay
why you fought you have see I mean you'd
think you'd have some I'm not that big
like you if you if I'm around other UFC
heavyweight I'm not big right but around
a football players now how does that
keep you from being injured because I
threw like Great Danes I Great Danes
always have [ __ ] hip dysplasia you
know I just think the big bodies break
down but it's a strain it's a strain of
the weight is a strain of every the body
mass absolutely thing yeah yeah it does
though no because it does big guys
always break first
yeah always absolutely right like you're
like it's 40 to 60 but your your big guy
but now but I'm big to you in pro sports
I'm not big I'm big to you as an actor
right in pro sports I am not about that
one why I would think that if you're a
bigger you'd have more padding and you
could take an hour but you don't have
knee issues or anything that's what I'm
trying to say no it's just rain it's the
strain it's all yeah all the tearing now
being and that height anything hit well
that doesn't help right but that's why
Rob Gronkowski who retired and I think
most people should know this no [ __ ] man
the guys had all those injuries he's
kind of done at all I need as young he's
just like yeah mountainous like Mike my
boy clapping Stein the main reason he
retired he was a first pick in the
second round to the st. Louis Rams and
then he just kept getting injured I was
like I'm so sick of being hurt wait I
remember after a game in Detroit Lions
wouldn't go see him play his first
touchdown catch and he we have to help
them walk up the stairs after that and I
was like Jesus Christ I know I'm a guy
in Miami we can help him out I'm out
yeah bleep protocol but you've been
around enough athletes you know I've
been athlete where when I see the stuff
with HGH and them going these clinics I
give here platoon if people only had us
hint of what those guys go through
everyone else would do it as well or
everyone of course everyone does like
you know a lot of most people to go to
the ant these anti-aging tunics are not
professional athletes they're just lay
people who want to feel good and they
want to reverse the ravages of time
they're learning yes I mean that's the
good things about the cell the cell stem
cells are like well of course what
constitutes a performance-enhancing drug
everything caffeine's are
performance-enhancing so he's so awesome
anyway I never had said good New Yorkers
love to hate him because they'd always
say he chokes during the playoffs and
they'd be like [ __ ] you know with his
blue lips and all the guys phenomenal
he's just he's um see him in person
whose kid was 64 230 handsome machine I
told you when I saw him in Vegas I was I
think I was with roguery that strip
steak house in Vegas yeah and there's a
whole table of us and a rods there with
two girls you singing up times there
with two girls at the bar and I go oh
you got a rose my favor love a-rod and I
look oh [ __ ] there's a rod and the guys
at the table top they go ah man [ __ ]
that guy I mean what the [ __ ] would you
but see what are you talk what do you
mean [ __ ] bad guy you know what he's
done for this guy this amazes you
kidding me this one the best baseball
players to ever live he's an interesting
character what's backpack firfer that
skill set he's in jail oh you [ __ ] he's
also he's also like a of his teammates
like him like he's also well like Disney